[Music]
do
a very big hello to everyone and a big
warm welcome to the
president's design award 2020 jurors for
one webinar
creating a better future by design
in conversation with design change
makers
my name is juliana yao and i will be
your mc for today
this event is organized in conjunction
with the president design award 2020
jury session
which just concluded yesterday it is
jointly presented by the design
singapore council and the urban
redevelopment authority
and supported by the national design
center
the president design award also known as
pda
is singapore's highest honor for
designers
and designs across all disciplines it
recognizes the achievements of an
extraordinary group of people
making a difference to the lives of
singaporeans and the global community
through excellent design it was
established in 2006
and is jointly organized by the design
singapore council
and the urban redevelopment authority
and since
its inauguration 41 designers of the
year
and 108 designs of the year
have been awarded in 2017
the president design award was revamped
to focus on
impact to emphasize the impact of design
in transforming work
and businesses raising the quality of
life
enhancing culture and connecting
communities
and advancing the design industry to the
role of the designer
this event here today is also part of
the national design center's
a future by design program lineup
for december 2020
today we are very honored to have five
esteemed panelists
from our president's design award jury
panel
all from various disciplines to share
about how design can raise the quality
of life
enable economic transformation and
create a better future
but before we dwelve into the session
proper i'll like to highlight a couple
of house rules
just to keep today's session running as
smoothly as possible
you want to be informed that this
webinar will be recorded
and that your microphones will be
automatically set on mute throughout the
session
however we most definitely welcome
questions
so if you do have any feel free to
submit them to the zoom
q a function should you encounter
any technical issues you can feel free
to reach out to our technical team
through the zoom chat function
and without further ado let us welcome
architect
mark wee executive director of design
singapore council
and architect larry young commissioner
general for singapore pavilion
at dubai world expo 2020 prize secretary
of lee kuan yew world city prize
and registrar of board of architects for
their opening address
hi everyone hear me
um well good afternoon to our guests
joining from singapore
in this part of the world and a good
morning or evening to those joining us
from across the globe
uh thank you for joining us today at our
president design award 2020 jurors forum
it feels really great to have the
support of so many friends
associates and enthusiasts from here on
the farm as we come together
to actually reflect on and super
unprecedented
simultaneous year that is 2020. it's
coming to an end
and look forward to optimism to how our
design community
can actually be a force of change as we
try to write a new chapter for 21.
indeed 2020 has certainly been an
unusual and trying year for all of us
and despite the challenges humanity has
prevailed
and it's heartening to see how singapore
and other nations around the world
have responded to the pandemic with
resilience adaptability and ingenuity
from professional designers and private
practice and in-house design teams
to local businesses and even the general
public
a spirit of entrepreneurship innovation
and collaboration has actually blossomed
out of this
tremendous constraints and many of these
stories can be
told through the lens of design and
design thinking
in the exercise of deep empathy for
marginalized groups
that emerge from the pandemic and the
collaborations across
different stakeholders to create
solutions for them showing
what i'm deeply convicted of the power
of design
for impact and this transformative power
and
impact of design is really at the heart
of the president's design award
and now more than ever especially
against this current backdrop
are we reminded of our responsibility as
designers and of
design's higher purpose in solving
societal challenges to create a better
world
i'm really proud to share that this
these ethos are demonstrated by the 2020
crop
of president design award recipients
that are esteemed
multi-disciplinary panel really who has
comprised of design leaders and impact
experts from singapore
china denmark spain and the uk just
selected in the past week
and if you were in a jury sessions with
us literally people are dialing up
from for the country four to five
countries around the world this was
course during this was of course during
the pda jury session
which adopted a blended format of
on-site and virtual interviews for the
first time
and with our local jurors here joined by
our international jurors without it
so we look forward to announcing the
results in may next year
during the award ceremony at istana
where we can come together
we're actually very privileged to have
five of our jurors here today
dick calling in from london
from singapore uh lakshmi calling from
barcelona
well b calling from singapore and
melissa
calling from singapore too with dick and
lesney joining us
from overseas really early in the
morning that's what i understand
hailing from different disciplines and
sectors the five of them will land
breath and depth
so the important discussion on how
design can drive change
and create a better world especially
right now
in the future fraud of uncertainty
for those of you in the audience this
evening i hope you'll also take the
opportunity to participate in the
exchange
especially during the q a sessions we
may be separated by time and place and
space in this virtual
zoom room but please let that not deter
your voice
from contributing to this crucial
conversation that will impact our
collective future
and i look forward to the next forum in
the next cycle where we can actually get
together again
with that i would like to wish everyone
an engaging discussion ahead and hear
how we can create a better future by
design and now i'd like to pass the time
over to my colleague from yori who is
also on my right at least on my screen
larry architect larry um for his remarks
larry please
oh thank you mark well distinguished
speakers
friends and colleagues ladies and
gentlemen
a warm welcome to the president's design
award
2020 jurors forum
of all the 13th edition so far this is
the 13th edition
of the president design award this is
the first time
that the secretary has adapted the forum
to a digital setting and it turns out to
be an excellent way for
us to connect with one another virtually
and to reach out to more people across
the different zones indeed
this year has been a challenging one for
all of us the events since the start
year 2020 have tested
the metal and resiliency of singapore as
well as the rest
of the world the pandemic
has served as a catalyst to rethink
the way we live work and play
while staying safe in months
following the pandemic outbreak
designers and architects have shown
their creativity and resourcefulness
in coming up with cutting-edge
engineering design solution to adapt
to the needs of their cities and people
i'm heartened that our design and
architecture community
has also caught up with the curve
the recent crisis has also shown
that designers and architects should
continually
enhance the understanding of the design
practice
and continue to innovate
good design is not only a hallmark
of a modern progressive society like
singapore
but also enriches and improves
people's life designing in response
to environmental and community outcomes
creating places that people want to live
in
and to ensure that human interaction
still feel meaningful across physical
and social distances will be all the
more
important under the current climate of
changing perceptions and priorities
designers and architects must innovate
and find better ways of doing things
to adapt to the new realities
in the new normal
to this forum i hope the discussions
among the speakers
will spur an open and lively exchange of
ideas
and more people will be able to
recognize the transformative
power of design and how it can
positively
impact lives and shape a better future
i also hope that every designer
especially our local design talents
will be further inspired to push
the design boundaries to come up with
game
changing innovations i wish
all present success in achieving
greater heights in the field of design
and architecture
with that i hand over the time to the mc
juliana to introduce the speakers for
the forum
and have a good day i suppose
thank you thank you very much to
architect we and architect um for their
very
encouraging words and of course it is
now my pleasure
to introduce our moderator and jury
member of the design panel
melissa qui ceo of the national
volunteer and philanthropy center
and on our panel today we do also have
dick powell jury chair of design panel
co-founder and chairman of seymour
powell
architect chan soo kian jury chair of
architecture panel
founding principal and design director
of
scda architects lakshmi
param miss warren jury member of design
panel and co-founder of the care lab
and finally welby eltador jury member of
design panel
group chief creative officer of city
neon holdings
so over to you melissa
hello and good day i think larry that's
a great
that's a great greeting because we're
not sure whether it's morning
afternoon or evening and it's probably
all of the above for everybody here so
um good day to uh everyone um my name is
melissa and it's a
super amazing privilege actually to to
host this with these um
four incredible um design leaders who
have had a chance to spend a little bit
of time with over the um
last couple days with the with the
president's design award and
and um truly they are they're each
um design leaders design change makers
so you are you are all
in for a for a super treat um actually
today
um you know it's the end of 2020 and
there was really no better time for um
us to reflect uh if we you know we think
about it we always say
time flies so fast and and you know
where did the year go
well you know when when one stops to
pause and reflect i think that which we
see um and and i think this year in
particular the things that we now can't
unsee uh we can we can reflect on them
a little bit more deeply uh and then be
a bit more intentional
uh about how we move forward into uh
into 2021
um you know i was i was uh telling my
team today too that that you know this
this would really be a year where where
we would where there was a lot of
revelation
things that uh things that we never saw
before i think mark spoke about you know
the innovation
the response um that was incredible um
but we also saw a lot of the gaps um a
lot of the the challenges and the
difficulties there
um but this led us to re-imagine um and
that's the next big r that's there the
the revealing but then the reimagining
and
and you know so many people have said
we're in for a great reset
you know we're in for a great reset um
so what does that look like
you know what does that look like in
this in this future that we're
approaching now with
a k-shaped recovery some people doing
amazingly
incredible wealth created at the same
time
great challenges for inclusion happening
to
business reflecting on you know what is
their purpose
what is business for good looking like
um you know going forward
and and for design design which is which
touches almost every aspect of life
um you know what then is the role of the
role of design and how are our
change leaders change change makers in
in in design actually responding so
we're going to look at all of these
different
um you know parts today but we're going
to start
um by something that's that's much more
that's much more personal
actually which is by asking each each of
our different panelists and i think i'll
kick off with uh dick because
he's so terrific and decided to give us
a video
um around this which was to introduce
themselves
um around reflecting on what 2020 has
kind of meant
for them so what so let's let's kick off
with uh with dick so
over to you dick first to introduce
juice yourself and your and your um
image thank you very much melissa well i
don't know
whether well let's watch the okay well
i'm just going to say a few words before
we see the video
um but i can see the video is running
there so
this is the work we did for virgin
galactic uh on the
design of the spaceship and of the
astronaut experience and
it was launched this year um and it's
particularly interesting because
it required new ways of working for us
of course forced on us by the pandemic
particularly in the in the area of
virtual reality and augmented reality
uh and these have really helped us and
point the way to the future of
for designers working in these difficult
circumstances and they've
caused us to create or build new skills
you know which we didn't have before
so um i i chose that project because
also it's a very uplifting and future
facing project that
is incredibly exciting to work on thank
you
where to go where no man has gone before
so
to boldly go indeed indeed
okay wonderful um so ken we're gonna
please tell us tell us a little bit more
about your observations in the last year
and
a little bit more about i'm going to
show two images
uh there are images of new york city a
city that
is close to my heart that i spend a lot
of time in
maybe three to four times a year and
what you're seeing
is times square the middle pandemic
how the urban realm has totally changed
next image and then
when the lockdown was lifted
how the city remarked itself in a
synchronized way
and adapted itself to the constraints of
not being able to dine indoors i chose
these two
images to lead into my talk later on
about the
regenerative powers of dense cities
[Music]
amazing wow oh
cities we cities we miss uh smelling and
and seeing directly huh
um amazing okay lesh me
tell us tell us a little bit about about
your reflections on the last year
so the care lab is based here in
barcelona
in spain and we're a very small
team all our projects are done in
collaboration with various networks
and when the pandemic uh hit back in
march
for us and we went into lockdown we
reached out to a community that we've
been part of for about 12 years it's a
global design research network
called reach and we have 18 partners
scattered across six continents and we
started to have regular calls every two
weeks
just to check in it just became a
meeting point
to share what we were all living through
personally but also what we were
experiencing with our design practices
in that moment and we kept up this
routine and rhythm
something that we hadn't done so
in such a structured way over the last
years and through these conversations
what emerged was
uh an opportunity to do a project
together
and so we kicked off a project that's
called care capsules
and the intention was to ask six
questions
around care and how people around the
world were experiencing care
during the care crisis and we
took each each of the partners ran
numbers of interviews in different
locations from talking to taxi drivers
in delhi to talking to social workers
in the netherlands we interviewed this
woman here who is a volunteer
here in barcelona for a foundation
called arels that work with the homeless
and she normally works within the center
but during the pandemic she started to
hit the streets and go out
to support people who were sleeping
rough
in the streets and one of those things
that melissa mentioned
what you see and can't unsee uh was the
fact that the city
um uh as was shown in the in the earlier
image it was
it was vacated so actually the homeless
would and the issues of homelessness
were stuck in that those were the people
that were still
living in the streets and she became a
frontline
worker in a sense and this is the other
thing that we can't unsee
since the pandemic struck is that
various professionals in fact
nearly nearly all of us have come a lot
closer to that role
of caregiving and also care receiving
and so these new roles emerged around
care
that we hadn't seen before we always
think of the
essential workers in the hospital but
people running the supermarkets became
care providers people delivering food
and products to our homes as well
became those front line caregivers and
that was a reframing that i think
has impacted our practice and and won't
be going away
anytime soon yeah
amazing i i i love the tagline of your
organization redesigning the world of
um our world of care together um
yeah i guess it's also affecting all of
our lives
and and welby who i think only speaks in
poems
um i'm going to ask um uh to share
to share next hi melissa hi everybody
um i wanted to share two uh two gif with
you
the first one i don't know if you can
see it if you can see it
properly on your screens but as a
creator
of of experiences
you know i also had to ask myself well
how do
we how do we create a better normal
you know when we look at 2021 and beyond
how do we do that and certainly for me
a question that has powered my practice
uh
you know throughout the year a question
that i'm sort of obsessed with
is how do we create amazing things
amazingly what what do i mean by that
maybe if you can you switch to the
second gif
in a way what i'm obsessed with is of
course it's about creating beauty
of course but it's also about how do we
create
a beauty in a in a way that nurtures the
people who are creating that beauty
i've seen too many times a process where
we are working towards creating
something beautiful
but the process itself is a little bit
toxic is a little bit soul-crushing
so part of my role as a creative leader
has been to really ask myself well how
do we create cultures
that are deeply innovative uh
very creative doing groundbreaking work
but in such a way that is also nurturing
the people
who are actually doing that work and i
explore those dimensions that you might
see
clearly or blurry on your screen but
essentially if i were to summarize them
i think that a little bit like lakshmi
that you have to start from a place of
care
um you know when we think about
innovation we often think about
the the final product or the final
experience
but i sort of think about you know how
do we create a foundation where
care comes first and that allows us
the opportunity to really uh uh you know
secure
uh you know safety uh you know i come
from the circus world and
one of the first thing that you do when
you work with acrobats
is to install a net before trying to
innovate
and that really is something that foster
that trust
and those three elements the care you
know the safety and the trust
these are the foundation for me when it
comes to
doing the heart of what we're talking
about when we talk about creativity
which is you know playing with danger
playing with constraint playing with
limitations
and i think this is only then that you
know it triggers those dreams it
triggers
that sense of breakthrough that brings
us to
eventually to grow and um and then you
know once we've grown once we've
really had those those breakthroughs
there's always a moment as well that we
need to design to recuperate
i find that when we think about this
better normal
it is a sort of metaphor but also maybe
a bit of a map
for really creating that better normal
um
at multiple levels so i'm looking
forward to uh
to the exchanges and and the discussion
uh in our panel today around those uh
those themes amazing
thank you so much um welby that's that's
so true i love that
i love that thought the better normal
when we say a new normal we kind of
don't really know what that means other
than it just isn't what
is now right but if we say a better
normal it it kind of forces
us to just to give a values perspective
actually on that too
so that's that's something that's that's
uh that's interrogating
um of each one of us but um yeah better
better normal how do we be better uh
live better work better
play better um in this new space so i
think the one question we want to
explore too is how the role of design
really has
has changed or or or maybe not changed
actually
um you know in this context than uh
going forward
um you know i'm wondering you know you
spoke a little bit you kind of
teased us a little bit there with your
sort of thoughts about sort of cities
can can you say a little bit more about
how you think
that that's affected us in cities i
think the role of cities
and the uh the nature of dense
metropolis uh has been debated a lot
and as designers we have gathered with
webinars trying to project
but i feel that it's not for us to just
project because we are still going
through change
and that means the ongoing is that what
i do recognize is that
the city is organic and it's
regenerative and it's resilient
so the question i asked is uh how has
kobe impacted the design of cities but
more importantly is this ends the end of
the dance metropolis
you know you you hear about the flight
to the suburbs
people leaving and then how can and how
has
the cities adapted but you know when i
think of a city i think of it as
being very resilient and the only
reference i have
is not my own projection but to look
back at history and how
people as a whole together with science
and engineers and social scientists
collectively we are resilient and the
cities come back
in a stronger different way so a lot of
times when people ask me can
architects reimagine what the new city
will be i said
no we can't really because we need time
to look back
but what i do know is that our
collaborators
our engineers that i work with all the
time they they could be the real heroes
you know you look at cholera you get
better sewers
and maybe you cover better mechanical
engineering hvac
but in our role as designers we tend to
be so heroic
and sometimes our collaborators and
consultants take a second role to
realize our vision
but i really think this time designers
need to open up
and observe the ground and collaborate
with more people more stakeholders
need to be involved with policy makers
this is really a collective effort
that will evolve but
what i do know from observation uh is
that
this particular time melissa uh it's a
brilliant time also because you see
people adapting uh
technology virtual meetings etc
and so be it with the cities yes some of
jane jacobs
writing about the role of the city and
the sidewalk in the public realm
all of a sudden it's happening most of
the time it happens organically through
market forces
businesses die and maybe you take on
certain planning roles
to allow outdoor eating but the slide i
showed
was that when the cars are
de-prioritized
you can actually have one lane you don't
need so many lanes
and why why is it the car is reduced to
one lane because people want bigger
sidewalks
they don't want to be chock-a-block so
they prioritize space for pedestrians
and then the regular sidewalk dining
goes to the street
and after that you provide another bike
lane because people
feel unsafe being in ubers and grabs so
these are the kinds of observations i
think designers need to look at
and to contribute to it rather than
again reimagine and reimpose them
i believe organic change is important
and i believe designers need to
look at what they can do to reinforce a
trend
but what i do know is that some of the
values that come
out from this change will stay there'll
be
a demand for new luxury of
outdoor spaces fresh air access to
nature
maybe even as my other parents said
we discovered beauty qualities like that
and and and this more human side of us
came out because we we are locked down
we all have time
to think we travel less
for example i think my typical year
involves traveling
over 200 days now stretch up
a beautiful stretch of 10 months it's
not easy
but i i i do have the time to rethink
and and
what what what came up from this was
that the role of the designer should not
be a heroic one
not in the time of condemning um
that is what that's what the thought
that came to mind immediately
especially more apparent in very dense
urban cities
so as we go along i'm sure some of my
esteemed panelists will have some
thoughts and we can have some
discussion but what i wanted
to say is that i've been attending a lot
of webinars
whether it's on sustainability or the
role of designing
sustainability i think it's time for
designers to to collaborate more on a
broader scale
with other disciplines in the humanities
yeah and that and that just helps to um
i i think what what was really revealed
in that respect
um was really the magnitude of the
challenges that that that that are that
are around us
and i suppose you know you you do it
yourself when
everything that can be done just
requires you but when the challenge and
the the
what is possible and maybe what is even
needed now is greater
then perhaps that common purpose is what
brings about that that um
that uh that desire to to collaborate
and reach beyond
you know one's one's normal you know
typical ways of uh
ways of working um that is truly so
now for example uh why should cities
even change if the vaccine comes by in a
strong way
this would be a period of a very bad
period
in history but cities will come back and
may come back look at
spanish flu then roaring 20s
when people are suppressed they come
back and they spend
then you have the the great depression
so
i i really don't know but what was
humbling for me was
the role of science and the role of
science and the world engineers are
magnified
and we are part of the the whole
ecosystem
we may design a part of it the delivery
systems is transportation
or even the design of certain facilities
that
need it yeah yeah and actually so
leaning into those
those those relationships in the
community and and establishing sort of
mutuality in some ways too i think lest
me that's what you kind of spoke about
too
is is how it kind of then activated um
you know all these different
relationships and communities and and
people just
stepped forth and and stepped out
actually um
beyond their various comfort zones too
how are you
seeing design you know that perspective
on design changing
in the community in the healthcare space
with with the elderly populations with
care homes
um what is what is that what is that
opening up for you
i'm building on on what's it was
mentioning
um it's true that
many health care and care providers
really struggled to reach what they call
the last mile
of care uh during the pandemic so that
was really the the last mile being
on the neighborhood scale in the
community scale
and that's where here actually in
barcelona also a very
uh dense city you saw
grassroots organizations and
neighborhood associations
gathering together in the sense of
solidarity and actually delivering that
that kind of care whether that's
dropping off
groceries for your next door neighbor or
helping out with
child care i think that was a phenomenon
that was heightened
during this period but it really did
shine a light on how institutions and
our care systems and services are set up
and why they were unable to respond to
some of these needs
and i wanted to share um specifically
about some work that we
are doing in singapore and in spain
both in the long-term care and
end-of-life care space
and these are quite extreme care
services um and yet they relate to
an aging population and they reveal a
lot of
taboos and preconceptions that we hold
about growing old
and the stigmas that lie around death
and dying and of course through this
pandemic
i think our relationship to these topics
really changed
everywhere in the world um and some of
the care homes that
we've been working with and more
importantly the care teams
that we saw who um on on a daily basis
are those essential workers but under
these conditions of
of the pandemic they really needed to
uh invent new ways on the fly
to figure out uh how they were going to
cope with
caring for the elderly and caring for
the for the
dying um and and in that regard
our role as designers and in in these
projects was to
carry the torch of the innovation work
that we'd be done because they were so
busy on the front line having to deal
with
far greater and more urgent situations
so we had to keep the projects alive we
had to give them space
we had to not leave their side we had to
journey with them and keep in touch with
them
and so the touch points with these care
teams reduced in frequency
and became open spaces where we would
just
check in and see how they were doing and
listen
listen a lot very deeply to what they
were working through as
a team um and this is if this is
was universal the conversations we were
having in singapore with hospice care
teams
and the conversations here with nursing
home teams and there came a point where
we realized that
the innovation culture had somehow
shifted in their organizations
whereas when we began these projects of
service transformation a year ago
there was a lot of resistance the design
is doing here
why are we thinking about doing things
in a new way
the pandemic kind of opened up the
purpose behind this transformation
and it actually helped people to align
around it so we saw momentum growing and
enthusiasm within the teens and an
urgency to want to make changes and do
things differently so
and though everything slowed down it
also picked up
and i was a really interesting tension
and i think
um the point about humility and the
point about
stepping back as a designer and really
listening to what is
what people are sharing with you either
verbally but also non-verbally and of
course as we start to work digitally we
lose some of this
um tactile interaction that we're used
to but it requires us to listen even
more carefully
for what people are living through and
therefore how can we
support this change and i
i just want to end maybe with uh with a
reflection that came out from
from these conversations that's very
positive is that i think
we can carry that torch
of hope uh because i see opportunities
for all of us to go through growth and
for
services and institutions and
organizations to really grow
as well we showed in his beautiful um
dynamic illustration that that that's
also
an advocacy role for design to bring
that hope and that possibility of
reinvention
for something better coming out from
from all of this hardship
of the last year yeah no that's so
that's so true and actually you know you
talk about it in terms of you know our
our health systems and care systems and
things like that and
and being attentive to the human
experience
um you know for somebody who
is is is very sick and an older person
who
cannot see other people you know in in
their last days just because of
you know coveted restrictions and things
like that is is is
is terrifying um but even even on
a very um you know everyday level too
just
i think so many of us in our own
organizations
have um just experienced how
that generalized anxiety in the system
you know
actually has has a has affected us too
and and you know
um you know dick you talked a little bit
about like the ways that we work and you
know whether you talked about that too
you know
how this affects us you know in in in
our ways of working
in in how we in how we um
how we create but also how we just you
know manage our our relationships
um our teams and even things like that
the cultures you talked about you know
within our organizations
um you know how do you think i mean how
has this
affected you and what out of this is
is shifting how you're moving forward um
maybe leave that open to to dick or
wellby to to kick off
okay well so i'll go first on that if
you like
you know i think the good news is is
that
business is more the same than it is
different um as a consequence of the
pandemic
i mean we've all had to adapt and change
and the interesting thing is that
business itself you know we're a design
and
innovation agency effectively working
for different clients and
they they've had to reach out for help
from us
to figure out how to to to keep things
as normal as possible
and to maintain you know good working
relationships and get projects delivered
you know we are
60 people based in london and when this
first hit it was super tough
you know everybody had to work from from
home learn how to do that we used to
call it
working from home you know that used to
be a sort of signal for actually taking
a bit of time off but
things have changed now um and we've had
to learn how to do that and we've had to
invest in putting
um sort of measures in place within the
office so covered covered related to
social distancing measures better audio
video and all the rest of that
but the really big thing has been the
the development of of
better skills in virtual reality and
augmented reality
um i mean we always had these
capabilities we've been building new new
vr tools in fact
uh to help with that and i showed virgin
galactic because
it's a good case study for for working
virtually you know we were able to build
physical prototypes of seats for example
and we would have a prototype in our
office
and um virgin would have one in in their
offices in mojave and we could actually
put those into virtual
spaceship so that you know people could
sit in the chair
you know do all the things that they
would be doing as an astronaut
and then they could feed that back to us
we could make changes they could make
changes so
we did all that and then i think the
other the other
really big change that's affecting us as
designers is that
um you know it was the the whole pr
launch of virgin galactic was done
with virtual reality you know we we
programmed 120 headsets which was sent
out to
various media channels and that meant
that uh the the virgin galactic team
could individually take journalists
around the whole thing you know through
the spaceport
through a 360 degree exhibition center
introduce them to the seats and the
layout of the spaceship
actually go into the spaceship and
actually take them up into space
so you know when we think about the
implications of that i think
and by the way we also did an augmented
reality app
which uh which allows anybody to
download the app and then to put a 3d
version of the seat or the spaceship on
their kitchen table
and and go around it look at it zoom in
on it and so on so
these are really important for our
future these these new tools because if
you think about it
uh all of uh business our clients
they're used to launching new products
through exhibitions and events and and
now that that's not possible
um at least you know not immediately
anyway
and if you if you imagine you're in for
example the luxury products end of
business and you make high-end watches
you know that
you don't buy a thirty thousand dollar
watch by pressing add to basket
you know there's a there's a whole
experience missing there that needs to
be replaced
so um these tools will allow those sort
of uh
people to have a relationship and
a direct sales relationship with people
buying their products you know we
as headsets reduce in price as people
like apple
and and others are developing new kinds
of glasses which allow you to
experience augmented reality i think all
of these tools are really really
important
for our future and another big project
we've been doing recently is a spinal
implant
um which is something that a surgeon
puts in your spine and you may say well
what's a designer got to do with that
well
we were able by working with surgeons
come up with an innovative solution
but the the big changes is that now we
can train
surgeons and train hospitals and nurses
in how to use that that those new new
products
virtually we can we can show them the
operation
we can instruct them how to how to use
it and all that is done virtually that
saves money and speeds things up and is
a better way of going forward in the
future
so the pandemic has force changed upon
us in the way that we work
uh good things yes bad things too
because we don't
we we have less time in the creative
environment with our colleagues
coming up with ideas but we've worked
hard to try and make that happen
i think definitely for for for you as a
sort of leader in the innovation space i
mean this
must have just been like 10 years worth
of work just kind of accelerated you
know into this
into this uh this period of time too
where just the need
um you know to to create more
um you know immersive and tactile
experiences just
in the absence of actually physically
being there
um you know must be so an amazing design
challenge and it's
i mean actually well it sounds a little
bit like you know what you do too you
know just those
immersive environments those immersive
experiences which
which which um which which are which are
sensual
which are beautiful um you know can you
how is that how has that also
impacted that sort of you know immersive
and sort of entertainment
entertainment realm too it's really
interesting because you know at big lab
and uh at city neon you know we that's
what we do right we create experiences
that
bring people closer together so how do
you do that during a pandemic
and uh you know and and it's interesting
as well because
vr in that context is the exact opposite
than what dick was was describing uh
it's almost like the
no go technology because of the
proximity because of uh
you know how do you scale an experience
like this uh
and so on and so on so of course it has
really
pushed us to explore for example how do
we create
experiences that are contact-less
but that still create as dick was
mentioning
this sense of a relationship and in
in our case very often a sense of magic
you know so in a way one of the
immediate impact was really the
reflection on interactivity
and how do we push that interactivity
for a long time
interactivity mostly meant a screen
that you touch and uh that was it but
what's exciting right now
is really exploring new ways
to um create that connection in that
relationship
between the guests and
an experience that we want to offer uh
to to our guest
we've been lucky because some of our
experiences have been
uh you know launched in china and uh
and and therefore we've had even through
the pandemic
a number of projects that had a chance
to still be
uh presented in a context of
of of the pandemic so we had a
a lot of great learnings um but as i
said i think it's really interesting to
explore
uh both the contactless experience but
that still
creates something that is magical and
and we're really observing that our
guests that's
they want to be recognized in the space
they want even more than ever
an experience where they are sort of
seen
as who they are individually and they
want to keep memories of that
and and sometimes they want to escape to
an experience that's closer to where
they are
because there's less traveling but we're
observing as well that people still
there's this hunger to travel somewhere
to
escape somewhere so the the
the offer from an entertainment
standpoint you know takes this new
dimension
uh and and i guess contributes to that
better normal
wow that's that's uh that's that's
fascinating you know i think i think
being able to
um both create that sense of um
you know rel relationship as you sort of
like you know say
um and and and how we do that now that
um uh maybe our our audiences and
and our cities actually are are so
diverse actually too
um i i would like to actually uh
swing us over though i realized to some
of the questions that have come in so i
i want to um pick that up um with with
one person here
who has asked us in the era of industry
4.0 or the
or the fourth industrial revolution and
the advent of ai
cyber physical development and etc how
do you think the fields of design will
potentially evolve um
i think i'm gonna maybe lob that over to
dick maybe to to kick us off but i would
love to hear from
from others from others too i love this
uh i mean we are at the beginning of
what we might even think of as a science
fiction age
you know we've we've recently witnessed
uh and are seeing
the development of um
uh you know virtual versions of
ourselves
um which we can put ourselves into these
virtual spaces and have the kind of
experiences that welby's been talking
about
that requires enormous artificial
intelligence
to actually produce and run those things
at scale
so these th we know because we speak to
these people these things
are happening you know where we are just
that far away from having a virtual
version of ourselves that
that we can through that through that
avatar
we can experience some of these things
and people were writing novels about
these things you know
only 10 years ago and yet they are you
know
they're upon us and and they're enabled
by massive advances in
in all kinds of things and the pandemic
has just accelerated all of that
you know so it's it's a fantastic time i
think and dick you know i would say that
uh i love that you say the age of this
of science fiction in a way uh or the
avatar
it's almost like uh i would push it and
say the age of the metaphor
you know are we about to become
metaphors
uh in our in our own ways you know i
think it's a it's an open question
uh but uh it's certainly an intriguing
one
and it's it's hard at least from where i
stand
to the surfer what will that all mean
uh you know for us it's hard to see the
future isn't it when you're
but we are actually in it you know i
often say the future is more the same
than different and it's difficult to see
that changes because of that
but nonetheless we are in a in a period
of fantastic change and so
you know obviously the person who asked
this question knows about these things
and is
you know following all these
developments and it's a it's exciting
it's exciting time
yeah i think that it's it's amazing i
think it presents both the sort of
utopic and dystopic kind of like
potential
that's there right terribly wrong
well i love that referred to
you know when you're talking about the
city and how it's resilient
you know for me i kept on hearing the
word solidarity
in a way you know there was a the sense
that uh the
the reason why there is that you know uh
more resilience at certain places
and less and others is almost like that
that glue
is that ability collectively to be
to express a certain form or solidarity
so that we can live together in a way
that you know that flows and makes more
sense
um you know i i don't know uh if you you
would you would qualify that way but at
least that that's the word that came
very strongly to me
i think cities are most known for
isolation but how do you move from
isolation to solidarity
um so you can any any thoughts on that
and i'd like to actually pull in leshmi
in a second to kind of get some thoughts
on the
the ai piece but i'll but right right
after this because it's uh
uh you know solidarity is important
special interest groups lobbies are
important but what i know is that
it presents an opportunity to reset for
a more
equal and generous caring society
the economic forces are decimating
office use for example
that's an opportunity to repurpose and
if there's lobby and there's policies
it could become for example elderly
housing in the city
why not uh diversity right
or it could be artist housing or
subsidized housing
so the segmentation of
zoning of cities uh a lot more woven
together
but of course it takes time for change
because there's attitudes or not in my
backyard
but at the end of the day i think
depending on policies and
politics and the kind of society you're
in
whether your government is authoritative
and top-down and caring and
catalystic or you're grown up democratic
this is an amazing time and a scary time
as well it can swing both ways
yeah no i i hear you i mean it it's it's
so true that i love that thought about
you know
repurposing office space to to be so
much more intentional
um about integration in the in the city
you know they always talk about what
freeways did to los angeles
um because when suddenly the the the the
low income housing was out of sight and
out of mind because you could literally
just
fly over it on the on the freeway you
know there became
you know a greater social divide just
because i never saw anybody
um and you never thought it was an issue
but um
yeah let's meet some thoughts some
thoughts from you on that too
yeah i think um i recognize this tension
that we're
talking about and i think just to circle
back to
uh the new technologies and and the
possibilities that they can bring i
think
they also bring a set of choices for
ourselves so if i
look at those possibilities just take
for example the story of the care homes
and
families who were not able to be
together when they were losing their
loved ones
the role of technology there and i think
we we talked about this with with
wealthy
earlier on the possibility of applying
all of those immersive and experiential
technologies to actually
let people uh have a sense of of being
together and of their community and of
that
intimacy that is so essential to all of
us but
particularly at the end of life and in
those last moments
how could we can we or should we be
taking those technologies and bringing
them
uh to people so that we're not seeing
um facetime farewells which is the way
that some people had to let go
and say goodbye to their loved ones
during that during the pandemic
protocols did start to be broken down so
for example
ordinarily wouldn't families wouldn't be
allowed to go into a care home to be
there for the for the last days or hours
but one family member was able to go in
and so they were
rewriting protocols to to humanize them
to respond to the situation
but i think as easily as we might um
consider
do we want to bring new technologies in
here i think we also have to confront
our own humanity and and think well what
kind of care are we willing to give in
these situations
and what we saw is that the care
professionals became
family to these residents and to these
uh elderly
because the family couldn't be there so
they stepped
outside or beyond their professional
role but in fact they absolutely
uh were following their uh intention and
purpose in the work that they do
and so they became the the family when
the family couldn't be present
and i think we have to also be open to
explore those
possibilities to get closer to one
another as well as thinking of what
possibilities technology can bring
when uh when that may not be possible
but i don't think it's an either or
i i think it's a hybrid messy
confronting
challenging but beautiful set of
possibilities in front of us
it's up to us to be human and imagine
right so
wonderful there is a question actually
that's just
come up too on i guess i'm wondering if
there's a
particular person that's directed to but
it says what are your views on a design
approach
or movement that is a fusion of
east and west in terms of culture art
and principles
of sustainability technology and
economic development
wow that's like a that's like a lifelong
quest question
but my reaction would just be that it as
in hasn't it always been that way
that there has always been those
influences
you know from east and west and uh i
don't know i
i'll be curious to to to to hear from
you know my colleague who's here you
know in singapore as well but uh i i
my sense at least is that i've always
been inspired by
by the east uh when i was in the west
and uh
you know there's always been this sort
of circulation and breathing
uh between uh those those two poles
should i go yeah absolutely sorry sorry
to disappoint but we're more the same
than we are different
and you know what's happened in the last
50 years is actually we've become
one humanity and there is less
difference between east west than ever
before and
you know when we're creating things when
we're really
creating them for everybody um but it's
only when you get into
you know particular aspects of art and
culture culture obviously very important
that you really have to take those
things into account but
i i welcome a future where we're more
the same that we are different and we're
one humanity
yeah that is that is very true learn
from me
that's here for me i want to respond to
that some something around the topic of
growth
and uh and growth not just in terms of
economic growth but also
as as a practice as a profession and
personally
and this was on welby's wonderful uh
moving diagram as well and i think the
i think there's a need for us to
reconsider what do we mean by growth and
at what cost
um and somehow in this question we're
looking at all of the different elements
that make for
um success for success for
sustainability
but also for a form of growth and i
would say
it isn't always about being able to to
do
more to be bigger to be better and it
happens a little bit to sujan's
values around humility as well and
understanding our place in the world and
understanding the kind of
relationships and collaborations we
might need to make horizontally
vertically all around us in order to
achieve
impact and this is where it links back
to
pda and what makes this award so special
and the program so special is that we're
we're not just talking about growth in a
very um
um simplistic way we're really looking
at levels of impact that range from
economic to social
uh and ultimately i think that's at
least for me a better
um pointer than than necessarily talking
about growing up
talking about the formal traditional
model of growth
i think there's a lot of people now that
are really you know questioning
is is growth really the the only or even
the best way to be to be about it and
perhaps growth is the principle of of
cancer and uh
growth for growth's sake is the
principle of cancer the growth for
purpose
um you know is is is perhaps a little
bit more uh redeeming
um and i'm just curious you know for for
all of you now too what would you say
would
i mean since since the president's
design ward now has been kind of shifted
in a sense to to focus on this idea of
of of
impact um you know and and and the
purpose in a sense of
of design what what what is what is
um what is what is one area of impact
that
that um that you're working on right now
that you can kind of
um that you'd like to highlight actually
as an area that has kind of shifted
you know uh with your maybe sharper
sense of
sense of i i can't
i can try to answer that uh
this is relative to our own right yeah
absolutely this is your perspective this
is from
uh when you were in a highly globalized
traveling world
um we acknowledge certain
urgent things were to do like
sustainability
but when you're locked down and you see
the impact what the lockdown could do
or on a personal level i know that i
can't make that change
myself because the momentum of of
of our work and the market is very
strong so the only way i can do that
is to collaborate so we try to
pair up for example a group called
palais for the oceans their ocean group
and we help them design their research
center on an island
and then we form scda lab and we try to
collaborate with ntu
or we need other people to come in so
i'm starting to realize
that the last few years when we actually
were actively traveling and
designing and flying around you're
consuming so much and doing so much
and the only way we can change and force
change is to have other
companies that are strong coming into
our practice
that's what we're trying to do and on
the smaller scale scda lab we try to
create this it's not uncommon but we
want to create
parts out of containers which is very
normal for most designs to use but
totally upgrade
solar and compostable toilet water
harvesting
and we created prototypes now and
actually built it so that we can try to
set that up
it's a small project but it allows the
studio to get a hands dirty and start
thinking about it that's what we're
trying to do i'm just curious you know
sukiyan what's the impact of that
been on your on your team it has been
very positive
we re imagining tender or indonesian for
as a new way of travel and not just in
the product itself
but to redefine hospitality as
experience based uh as dependable or
community for example tender
should be set up within an hour or two
from a village
and your food will come from the village
so we re-imagining the whole ecosystem
of hotels
so it's just architecture i'm just
trying to broaden
so the the the the more so designers
operating kind of trans-disciplinarily
in that sense
with local communities involving them
and sort of giving back because when you
when i think of these
tenders they currently be in remote
places
increasingly new new millennials they
like to travel
not in total luxury but in for
so that has been a very nice side
project a great distraction from
architecture and doing luxury
which we do a lot yeah that no
absolutely
any any other changes just curious for
for you and any of your lives will be or
or dick or lesh me too just this
sharpened sense with with your
with your practices yes i mean i think
i sort of touched on it a bit earlier
but i mean we have a team at seymour
park or foresight and their their job
is to map the future their research
team and a strategy team and their work
is really rocket because
clients are finding it harder than ever
before
to really track the changes in people's
lives that affect
the things that we buy and use every day
and they
and they need creative people uh
like our foresight team to research and
find out
how these changes are affecting people
so that
we can make better products you know and
that's why
also i mentioned the spinal implant you
know
there are huge medical companies out
there whose job it is to create these
kind of
very small but detailed parts that go in
our bodies
and you would say well why designers you
know what are designers doing there but
we were
we what we were able to do was to work
with the surgeons
extensively with the surgeons the
research team could work with the
surgeons and listen to the surgeons and
watch what they did
rather than just kind of do some you
know
corporate research we were able to
actually observe them in action
and put ideas to them so that we could
uh together co-create something that
would ultimately make a difference
yeah i i love that i love the idea of
coke creation
uh and it's certainly an area that we're
exploring especially because
if i take your question melissa from a
more macro
level what we try to do and every day
is is simple yet complex at the same
time we
i've mentioned it before but we're
really trying to
take those really fun inspiring stories
and we try to bring people where
perhaps would never go to the same space
together
to experience you know those those uh
those different spaces
and we think that this is a way to
essentially bring people who are
who maybe feel very different in a world
where
it's sometimes not promoted to
uh to have people who are different who
are being in the same space together
so in a way for us you know and for me
certainly that's a big motivation to my
work
is how do we create those spaces how do
we create those experiences
that brings those people together and
maybe for two hours for one hour
uh suddenly they realize as dick was
mentioning earlier
there is much more that connects us that
uh you know makes us different or
divergent from each other
uh and and it's something to celebrate
yeah that's so that's so true that's so
true
lash me i think you wanted to mention
yes i want to join in the celebrating um
when we set up the care lab our
intention was to create a platform
to uh enable others
who feel strongly about transforming
care to meet one another
and so that means going well beyond the
design discipline but also opening the
doors to to anyone and everyone who
thinks that we can do an awful lot
better in how we care for
for each other and so through this
this year this incredible year we
found that one of the things that really
sharpened in my mind about our practice
is that as we were journeying with the
various groups that we work with
and that is already fairly
multidisciplinary and international
we found an opportunity to actually
connect those people to support one
another
and so to create a platform and
because we could work online we could
literally
stitch up stories from around the globe
and have people come together
not necessarily to with an intention of
creating something but of
beginning a conversation and sharing
some of the frustrations some of the
challenges just offloading
basically some of their issues in in
trying to
for example keep their
social service running within
say within singapore with city council
members here who are trying to do
exactly the same thing but in a
barcelona
city context or connecting people who
are pushing
on a level of of policy and more
structural change with grassroots
organizations and frontline workers so
we've we've found there was a chance to
actually
be the platform be the connector and and
in a way
it's an aspect i think of design moving
forward that is
is important for us to to recognize that
through those conversations will then
be opportunities for us to apply our
designerly capabilities and skills but
maybe the first thing we need to do is
to just let people
meet one another who have common um
interest and purpose in in mind
and and how and how do we then design
organizations
or cities or spaces then to facilitate
that
i think the part of that conversation
is finding the leaders within those
different groups so within
here in barcelona within the city
council we work very closely with the
social rights team
which is a diverse diverse group that
are working on a number of different
social topics within the city context
but they have their uh they're in their
bubble
and quite rightly so they have so much
to focus on um
but by connecting them with uh
um urban planners and strategists
and and designers who are working on on
community-based service solutions
it opens their eyes and vice versa so i
think that
in these connecting of worlds is where
the creativity and
new possibilities can flourish and the
energy levels just go up
because suddenly they start to see
to absorb new ideas know from outside of
their
their particular realm so it's about dot
connecting
um and i feel that this year a lot of
our practices
has has also been also been about that
which sets the stage for some of the
transformations that you
that you mentioned like how do we design
all the better questions to ask
ourselves right how do we design our
cities
to be resilient to all kinds of crises
not just a
care crisis um yeah i'd say another
another aspect of this is uh um how do
we
create experiences and space um that
allow people to be recognized
you know so it's a form of
personalization but i think
personalization can sound a little bit
corporate but
how do i how how do i get recognized in
this space
you know for who i am wherever i am uh
that's you know an area where i'm very
intrigued
to leverage technology to create those
little moments of magic you know where
maybe
you go through a life and you you know
people don't necessarily have a lot of
opportunity to be
to be recognized and appreciated for who
they are
and and suddenly you know the space um
you know maybe people around you
recognize you
uh acknowledge who you are uh
acknowledge something that you love
uh that's always a something special
especially
when you're not expecting it so i think
that's uh that's an area where
um we're doing a lot of research um to
create those those small moments
actually that's so true the question of
how how you create i think part of it
is around having people feel like
they're seen um
as opposed to just being an anonymous
kind of dot you know floating around in
uh
in the in the in the ether um and uh
and and i suppose when people are seen
um when people are
valued and when people do feel valued um
their gifts are more easily brought
forth um you know and that's actually i
think what we've
what we've seen within this last year is
the need for really everybody
to uh to sort of step step forth and
step in
step into that as well um
i i have a question um you know um for
for um for us around the role of design
and education
actually um you know it sounds like
there's there's there's almost skill
sets now that
um that are almost competencies of
design that
that are almost like life skills um
it sounds like um you know for you if
you were advising
let's just say for for for hypothetical
sort of like purposes like
you know um uh an education system a
government system
what would you say would be key
competencies we are currently
lacking or key competencies we would
need to amplify
in this in this new better normal from
it from from a designer's perspective
well should i start with that um yeah
let's go dick
yeah i mean i think here in the uk you
know when we talk about our education
system we introduced design and
technology to school curriculum many
years ago
and that had an enormous effect
actually on the creative industries we
have a we have a very potent creative
industry here in the uk and one of the
reasons for that is because of
introducing
design and technology into the classroom
at the age of eight
and but sadly because of politics and
this that and the other
that has gradually become diluted to the
point where now it's merging on the
non-existent and that is going to have a
catastrophic effect on
on the on the education of our children
exacerbated of course by the pandemic
and their inability to actually practice
a lot of the things that they're being
taught so
right now i think if you ask me the
question what can we do it would be to
put design and technology back into
schools
and give it a serious push you know and
you know we're very kind of based in our
schooling system these days on the
things that you can add and count and
put on a spreadsheet
you know not the creative skills that a
lot of kids are really good at
and that that that needs nurturing and
and
where would you focus that education
from
from a very early age you know just like
we did before i mean it's become diluted
but you know
the kids were doing designing technology
at the age of eight
wow so just when you're starting school
it's like
go build your toys
you know it's difficult obviously with
the pandemic but designing technology at
the age of eight kids could go
into a workshop and make things and
you know accept challenges and figure
out how things work you know and it's
sorely missing in education i think that
that almost what we used to call the
vocational skills you know but they are
so important
i think to educate and maybe to
reinforce what dick is saying here and
and just to circle back to what i was
sharing at the beginning
you know for me it's i see a net
you know and uh yes there's that cliche
of giving
people space to fail but frankly you
know
that workshop that dick is referring to
that experience sense of experimentation
means that many times what you will try
will not work
and it's still very surprising today
to see um in a new generation um
where uh there's such a fear of
failing and such a sort of
adoration almost of of trying to be
perfect and it's really something that
stifles
your ability to push you know and try
things and
experiment but it's very hard to do this
when there's no net
it's very hard to say to an acrobat
please
uh experiment with this new figure you
know
with uh triple salto and uh what what
not
but there's no net there's no security
you basically have to
yeah you know uh make it work the first
time so i would say you know
add more nets early age education
and i'm just wondering whether parents
are almost the first educators too but
sukan sorry you were going to say
something right i mean to welding's
point
that sense of security especially in
regard to our education system
here the introduction of basic
design thinking is important in lateral
thinking
because so much of our education is
about
finding a solution empirical solutions
or quantifying success
and it is the parents even when you want
to loosen up
the parents are so concerned about being
able to measure
so when you want to impose a new way of
educating kids you
you do have to educate the parents and i
i
on that point itself that's for the
younger
kids education but on a tertiary level
university
i see a trend towards broadening in
architecture schools about
cross-disciplinary uh
studying but i think we need to separate
it into two streams
one is very general and you still need
to keep one stream that's very
traditional which is a
professional stream but the guys that
general can fit into all kinds of work
in the new economy they can be bankers
they can be
anything so i think design education is
very valuable and there's almost a
mindset
sort of change it needs to sort of uh
happen i think because uh
i think at least traditionally here it's
been it's been sort of valued
um as less than um you know say going to
be your
uh banker or a lawyer or whatever but
you know going back to our ai
conversation we know which jobs are also
kind of uh going away so
maybe there is maybe there is a a sort
of redeeming element
to being able to to ask the right
questions and sort of like
be human and and and imagine uh and
build
right um yeah let me your thoughts on on
on the education
piece too yes because i was straight
last year we came across this book
called the hundred year life which
written by an
economist and psychologist not some of
you you know yes
um and when you think about how we build
up skills in the education system in a
very linear way
20 years of learning and then we need to
end up
being able to work into our 80s now so
those skills just becoming obsolete
and where i feel some uh
design um the design mindset
could actually play a role in that is is
in
enabling kids and at a young age to
realize that they
can and they should expect to
reinvent themselves over and over and
over
throughout a lifetime so it isn't about
um
skilling up getting that job and and
hanging on to
to one definition of success in terms of
professional
life and we've seen over the course of
this year with everything being shaken
up
that in order to be resilient as
individuals
and to thrive in this really uncertain
and um and unpredictable world
is the ability to be able to ask your
reflect
ask yourself uh what matters to define
your own
question your own direction and to have
the skills but also the
the courage to try things in a new way
and to reinvent and children do this
naturally
we just sort of drain it out of them
along the way
what we need to be doing is building
that uh
reflected practice and also constructive
and
dreaming practice that should be part of
then
uh the way in which we define success
because it's about
sustaining and ongoingly sustaining uh
and looking after one another in that
process
um yeah i'd say there's something almost
counterintuitive to it because
in a way it's about you know raising
entrepreneurial
artists or entrepreneurial creators
um you know were able to as actually
saying is you know reinvent you know
not only reinvent himself but recognize
new opportunities as well
yeah actually and and really just having
that perspective to learn
this is a funny thing but it's actually
true my hundred-year-old grandmother
made me these earrings
um and it's it she kind of picks up new
uh
new skills every every year so she's now
into like necklace-making so
but you know it's it's it's just i
suppose just maintaining that that
curiosity and learning posture you know
no matter you know how old you are but i
think i think
we have one one one question i actually
just want to wrap up with and
and you know we have we have a 160 odd
whatever participants you know
here here watching actually on on this
call right now too and
and you know many of them are our
designers or design even design
enthusiasts
um some policy makers too but what
advice would you give
actually you know to to designers um
you know your people in a sense to our
people
um you know about uh how to thrive
um how to how to stay relevant how to
flourish
in this better normal as as as well be
said what's what's one piece of advice
that you would give and and maybe why
that piece of advice
who do you want to start
anybody can anybody with that urge all
right i'll i'll uh i'll start by saying
this
i think work from a place of conviction
and
openness so i think it's both important
to
you know develop that intimacy with that
voice
that you have where you feel
you know this intuition that tells you
you know i want to go in that direction
or
i think this is the right angle or the
right approach
yet at the same time you know find
uh that muscle of openness and ability
to also recognize
from the environment from feedback and
so on
what are those pearls or that gold that
you are receiving from
people around you in their comments in
their
reaction positive negative you know
essentially don't take anything
personally um you know it's it it does
become a superpower when it comes to
designing things
awesome thanks wilby
did i go yeah absolutely core bit of
advice
first would be don't give up right this
is the most
the most rewarding job you can do i mean
i think being in a creative industry and
doing these things contributing to
society is the most
fantastic thing to do but the pragmatic
piece of advice i would say to young
designers is
you know focus on something you're
really good at you know because
design is such a broad church that you
and too many designers try to do a bit
of everything
but you could really make a contribution
if you focus on the one thing in that
whole range of possibilities and do it
really well
i would build on both of those fantastic
pieces of advice once you
realize your conviction and you connect
with the community around you and
stick says you realize what also what
you can bring
to that i would say ask yourself how can
you
have the biggest impact for everything
that you do
um through the community through the use
of your super power your skill how can
you scale it and spread it
to bring that uh uniqueness to as many
to touch as many lives as possible
you need to ask yourself this question
hmm
awesome loving impact likely
that that is one of the hardest
questions because i've answered it in
different forms at different times
at the end of every interview but when
you throw in kovit it's
so different i just want to say a very
practical level
for designers if you're looking for work
right now it's very difficult
but you can work outside your field
as you work on many different areas
outside your field
the dots will connect because our field
is
so broad they all will connect and
the only thing you need to do is not
lose your bearings you're a designer
be curious believe in it stay through
uh be yourself so know yourself but you
can devil for example
if you're a graphic designer you can be
a construction worker i i think they all
connect it's about process and
materiality
and the last bit of advice is i don't
think globalization is dead
we need to to think broad we all
connected virtually
so it's still a very globalized world
i love it that's great so we have
stand with conviction and openness don't
give up go deep
think about have the great how to have
the biggest impact
with your work be curious be yourself
globalization is not dead okay
so i think um i think it just
leaves me to to thank these amazing
panelists thank you for
for being who you are and doing what you
do um
in this space we are definitely i i feel
encouraged at least that we can create a
better future
um by design um with with you all out
there
so that is amazing um i just want to now
actually hand it back to our
head back to our mc so thank you one
last thing melisa you've done a
fantastic job
weaving us together the last couple
hours
and even though we're on such different
fields you know
you managed to make the whole talk seem
like one
coherent synchronized discussion thank
you
absolutely you've been giving thanks to
you and an honor
to your colleagues to uh to share the
zoom screen with uh
all of you thank you alrighty
thank you so much back to our mc
definitely very insightful sharing thank
you so much once again to melissa and
all of our panelists
for that so with that we have actually
come to the end
of our webinar and we'll really
appreciate it if you could help us to
complete a
simple survey for this webinar at the
same time to help us improve
on our future programs a link to this
form is also being shared right now
via the zoom chat and if you would like
to find out more about the various
upcoming programs
at the national design center do also
scan the qr code that you see on the
screen
thank you once again to all of our
speakers and to
all of you for spending your tuesday
afternoon with us
we most definitely hope to see you again
at our future
events and with that we shall end the
webinar with a
short inspirational video this video is
an
open letter from singapore to the world
about our commitment to staying together
and working with businesses to emerge
stronger together
despite the ongoing pandemic thank you
and enjoy
dear world once upon a time
we had an impossible idea to turn sea
into land and land into one of the
busiest airports in the world
a gateway for dreamers a runway
for believers
but now our world is not quite the same
we are in the toughest crisis of our
generation
our skies are quieter and our streets
too
but it's also in this quiet
that you can hear the belief
and in the emptiness
see the resolve and resilience of our
people
[Music]
and just like once upon a time we now
look not at what we see
but at who we are and not a what if
but what's next are people who stare in
possible challenges in the face
and say no we won't be beaten planes can
be grounded
but our spirit never dear world
together we will rise again
[Music]
me
do
[Music]
you